he's ambitious amazing and simply
inspiring in honor of bendier when
turning 18 we have 8 reasons why we love
the conservationist let's relive her
biggest moment so far did you want to
tell everybody what you're gonna be when
you grow up
that was little bindi adorably sharing
she wanted to follow in her father Steve
Irwin's footsteps he's a huge part of my
journey in life the wildlife enthusiast
is successfully preserving her late
dad's legacy at the Australia Zoo and to
celebrate her milestone bday she's
spending her day at the Animal Park
the Dancing with the Stars champ
deserves all the awards for this
emotional performance dedicated to her
dad you've been the shining light of
this season with your joyous spirit and
determination for perfection on the
dance floor and in life bindi encourages
the people around her with her happy
demeanor her smile is contagious and she
enjoys taking selfies just like the rest
of us
Plus bindi and her boyfriend Chandler
Powell are relationship goals the
Chandler is one of the kindest people
I've ever known and just loves wildlife
and conservation and it's great to be
able to find somebody who shares the
same values the conservationist takes
modeling to a whole new level posing
with snakes skunks and exotic birds in
semi formal wear above all the young
starlet never forgets where she came
from
Australia will always be my heart it's
been my hottest let's face it what's not
to love about the deer win I'm excited
to see what you have to come